my name is beyond rich that I'm the  world's greatest Gatecrasher of all time  Superbowl 12 my ultimate goal was they  get a picture with Tom Landry I got  permission from red Miller the coach  with Denver to get on the bus and my USA  today like this because they never know  who might come by and spot the bus  pulled right up the field you have to  walk in with a crowd you walk in by  yourself his security offers you're  gonna come up on ask your field  Prudential I was right there where  they're making the plays my heart's  going about like [ __ ] I started easing  my way over into the position to get  Landry on my shoulder right at the time  at that clock hits me I'm like this  close to him red Miller comes across to  congratulate me and he sees speak right  there were glance be on my shoulder that  picture is in the NFL Hall of Fame he  had no idea that would ever happen to  none whatsoever